alors dit moi est ce que tu crois que
magee le célèbre feuilleton d'antenne 2
animateurs de l'a5 way est ce que tu
pourrais que maggie t'aide à vendre ton
biz qu'est ce que j'en dis oui bien sûr
c'est certain que la notoriété que j'ai
eu avec mme heidi a aidé à la vente du
disque sûrement dis moi tu as été choisi
comme en bons rails et j'ai été choisi
par la première productrice qui était
une canadienne était arrivé en france et
qui à chercher parce qu'au départ c'est
un feuilleton américain qui s'appelle
mode mais on a très peu utilisé
les sketchs parce que s'il ya quand même
une différence énorme entre l'umoa
méridien et mon français par exemple
dans mots de la personnage principal la
famille d'ilan pour les français et tous
le tambour et en france ça peut pas
tellement rire une femme qui est tout le
temps leur est un peu pour me mettre de
temps en temps ça fait rigoler mais une
bonne femme qui a hier le g8 social et
pour les américains ça les fait rire les
choses comme ça tu as retrouvé rosy
varte alors tu avais connu o'dricoll
chez fontan oui et puis que j'avais
surtout vu à l'époque où elle faisait
partie de la troupe d'yves robert ou
alors autre rouge
comment ça va avec elle très bien ses
jeunes amis qui travaillent sur les
séries qui m'a dit que c'est pas le
grand amour entre vous c'est vrai on
peut ranger - non ça va bien très bien
oui ça va préférer que ça s'appelle
georges lui de s'appeler m'a dit toi
notre but you trop de problèmes c'est
rapporte beaucoup de fric oui
ouais bien sûr chaque année tu fais tu
fais un peu monter les enchères pour
basse et j'ai un contrat comme ça un
contrat qui prévoit que chaque année 7
secondes
ouais ça va faire qu'un jour il fasse
mourir un jour tu leur coûtera trop cher
il dérape george et lisa gardien passé
c'est le truc classique des feuilletons
bah ouais mais elles disent prendre à un
gigolo et puis voilà mais voilà partis
pour toi tu n as pas marre d'être jura
laufon
non et je n'ai marre des fois le matin
en partant de chez moi en me disant je
vais
au studio tous les jours à la même heure
un peu comme mon bureau c'est pas la
peine d un artiste pour fermer à tout le
temps et puis quand j'y suis on se marre
bien ce style bien non non mais c'est
pas comme les peuples marc non plus de
jouer des sketches avec roger depuis 15
ans les mêmes presque mais t'as pas
envie d'être une ordure s'est passé
l'été dans des doors déjà été dans un
film avec maria casarès jorge henrique
est une pièce à à une pièce de
bernard-marie koltès aux amandiers de
mise en scène de patrice chéreau quai
ouest et ouest étaient vraiment avec
immonde mécontente été odieux là oui
j'ai l'action et le maquillage est à
dire c'était tellement dieu qu'un jour
le garçon qui jouait mon fils aux
répétitions étaient tellement excédé de
notre dans une scène qui m'a pris comme
ça 1 1 pendant les répétitions mais dit
mais vous n'êtes pas d'enfant vous alors
il y avait une haine qui s'est installée
tu fais bien le dieu quand tu veux oui
mais ma guise est en place comme de
faire du cinéma du théâtre des trucs un
peu plus oui sa maman crédit quand même
c'est vrai mais bon c'est pas parce que
c'est quoi tu sais c'est trois jours par
semaine le 10 heures du matin à 8 heures
de jeu
s'il joue encore six jours par semaine
c'est le baril
rôle bein oms buy il s'agirait non belle
s'est effectivement j'ai dû refuser
certains rôles au cinéma ou au théâtre
mais à succès c'est un succès s'est pas
bien je rejoins c'est une bonne mémoire
parce que vous apprenez dans l'année
l'équivalent de 17 pièces de théâtre
avait annoncé à oui c'est ça c'est le
côté ap terrible mais tu sais la mémoire
c'est comme c'est comme n'importe quel
le cerveau c'est comme n'importe quel
autre muscle terrain tu fini par
apprendre plus facilement un cas au
début qu'à la fin c'est maintenant je
lis deux fois une page glace et de
vapeur des doors jacques dit maintenant
réduit mon âge que c'est un peu la même
réponse c'est vrai que quand vous
changez un détail de la décoration du
décor les gens les gens râlent mais déjà
rage et on avait écrit dès
des sketches pour sortir un peu tout à
ces épisodes les aux sports d'hiver
suivent le tour de france
qu'est ce qu'on apprend qu'en l'état
leur en belgique sur les canaux les
jungles là ils aiment retrouver là je
pense eluard de la production c'est bien
ou pas oui pour l'amour d'écologie alors
même port pin alors tes idoles de
millions de français puis maintenant 2
millions bruce aussi parce que c'est
diffusé en numéraire en russie ah oui
oui ça a était jusqu'à maintenant en
grèce en espagne je crois un en
argentine en russie et surtout pas le
continent américain puisque évidemment
il ya les droits et ils restent sur
monde
est ce que quand tu seras une star
mondiale ce qui est en passe d'arriver
tu feras des produits à ton effigie je
pars l'aïoli jean marc thibault par
exemple à l'aïoli oui j'aimerais bien
mais
ddd t-shirt par le temps avec la gueule
qu'elle veut avoir dans dix ans
peut-être problème l'aïoli tu serais
d'accord à willaya luchat d'accord oui
j'adore l'aïoli dans tout le regard d'un
truc tu vas voir